this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
we are here for what if season 2 episode
two today joined by Koy jandre Koy we
just watched episode one did you love it
loved it flabbergasted confused excited
for more you got to watch our reaction
to that ladies and Gentlemen please go
ahead leave a like on this video that'd
be very much appreciated also tell us in
the comments down below what do you
think of this episode of episode 2 if
you're here that means you already
watched it so tell us what you think
people people think thoughts they might
not have then they yell us were talking
too much I don't know why they're here
why are they talking over the the show I
want to watch well maybe watch the show
yeah watch the show leave a like while
you're at it too leave a like also
subscribe and click the notification
Bell get notifi when our reaction for
episode three is up here on the Chanel
thank you to prep for helping us seted
down these highlights you guys are
champions also uh full length Reaction
watch s where you sync up with your own
copy of what if that is available for
super sexy rejects thank you to all who
have been joining helping us have the
most uccessful year at our patreon thus
far Coy you ready to get into it let's
do two we don't know what the titles for
any of these are we going blind we have
no idea what we're walking into right
now but let's do
it Commander do you have eyes on the
target barely it's moving fast is that
gorgeous animation again copy that
weapon fire it
will Dragon Ball Z it's going down
where 1988 oh it's going to be that
episode oh the 80s Avengers episode oh
cool I right I
assume you destroyed a generic water
building the year I was born
Aqua yes who's in the egg
rits right there I can see you a
Star-Lord is that a kid not just any kid
but Peter Quill
yeah a son of Earth and the Stars whose
pain and loss now threatens to destroy
the very world he once called home oh
and the entire universe along with it oh
no he went the way ego wanted him
to that's dope that's a fun what if I
love that that's again more like the
comics like what if have something
big John Slattery oh Howard Stark here
Chris Hemsworth's
back oh Lawrence Fishman's back okay oh
I saw Sebastian Stan I'm wondering if
they're gonna set it like he came back
in the 80s instead 6 months earlier the
ravagers were dispatched to abduct Peter
Quill from his home
world oh so it right away right away
yeah and chose to raise him as his own
and the ego got pissed but in this
universe yandu never had his change of
heart so he turned Peter over to his
father the celestial being known as ego
he's pretty you won't be needing these
anymore Peter
no let's play catch ego called it the
expansion to remake the universe in His
image and with his son now at his side
he had all the power he needed absolute
power corrupts kids absolutely
orbital intelligence has retraced his
steps across dozens of nearby solar
systems Ric pegas this okay Cosmic
radiation within 24 hours of his arrival
Peggy Aging in real time this kid has an
entire nuclear Arsenal csing through his
veins with that kind of Firepower I
don't know that there's a person on
Earth who can stop him it's like a breit
bur situation yeah not one person
working alone but a team made up of the
best our little planet has to offer
Peggy assembles The Avengers in a matter
of minutes Howard at the rate he's going
our planet Won't Last a Day we need help
okay who's on our roster yes there's no
vegetable the potato chips are the
vegetable oh Ant-Man yeah Michael
Douglas and you're supposed to be a
scientist and you're supposed to like
potato
chips godamn hope you're such a pain in
the ass J say you Hank please don't hang
up oh that's right him and Howard got
their beef yeah yeah turn on the TV what
the aircraft's occupant was send the
plane one step ahead of you awesome this
is their Hulk like The Avengers Assemble
over the Hulk and this is like the
Insight against that's great used to
work sweetie not anymore this is so cool
smart to keep the relationship between
them yeah what Foster oh my goding it's
me
Qui I guess technically Loki would be
the better parallel but let's like at
the Loki threat wow who's the guy in the
armor King tachaka oh
tachaka it's a pleasure your father was
a great Ally to US during the war yes I
understand you even donated some
vibranium to your efforts we made a
shield out of lost it in the Arctic
but cool ORF wanted the target contained
before he reaches Moscow so he sent the
Winter Soldier yes
o oh
oh love it great attention and
detail like Bucky heard the rumor
perfect even if they're true the man we
knew is long gone pig and we have bigger
fish to fry I miss winter soldiers so
much what a cool moment why is this
season off to such a better start it's
so much better these are actual what if
Comics it's using multiple characters
it's actually weaving a big enough story
are we even going to be able to
intercept him in time New York's a long
way from the Mojave Desert not in my
ride hello Dr Wendy Lawson US Air Force
Wendy Lawson uniform doesn't really look
like Air Force it's not it's cre Star
Force they met the cre in the 80s I
guess pre 90s Captain Marvel Catman
space BR giant man silent but deadly
good to see you and you're going to be
the Crusty guy I was just saying I love
how you get a fun side of Hank Pim yeah
young instead of just a km that's more
Ant-Man in the comics yeah it's
perfect
this kid puts on quite a
show well you better that child take him
out bre bur duck a PR bunch of Rocket
raccoons it's also paced more like a
movie he does not look all that
threatening books can be deceiving you
think the leader of a technological
superpower that masquerades a third
world country would appreciate that or
those foxes okay I'm at the crash site
moving in to secure the Pod ship now
everybody in position relax I got the
perimeter go jant yeah my go I seem to
remember you maxing out at 21 ft yeah I
made some adjustments he figured the end
the world go big or go home you two are
finished measuring your
States if you can isolate the kid you
should be able to trap him in the photon
grid you cover the Trap I'll handle the
boy oh great sense of scale that's
perfect what's the matter kid what
something bugging you nice done luring
him to your position now Tech's Advanced
it's going to take me a minute to crack
it smart to do small things that he
wouldn't necessarily attack right away I
really feel like they're taking
advantage of their animation this time
with the Ant-Man stuff yeah and it's so
much more cinematically paced than the
first season I remember
[Music]
being resistance will only make this
more difficult my young friend
[Music]
not the move T Chaka I feel like Peter
would
anate I got him oh no oh no
cool pull back killer if the cub in that
jet blows there won't be a planet left
to stay shoot him Winter Soldier shoot
that child has Sebastian Stan spoke at
all he hasn't spoken yet but he's in the
cast
[Music]
great use of scale and animation Problem
Child
12:00 does anyone have a plan dope
Avengers lineup I've got a plan
Retreat okay let's
go
just weird presence it's like a weird
goth
character
Thor no way is see that big of a
threat
yeah this is his first time on earth oh
it would be yeah is it really you if you
are referring to your doom then yes I
thought you were the dude from Van
Halen yodenheim was the first to fall
Asgard soon thereafter oh perished
at that boy's hands damn until this
realm Earth was all that remained it is
like The Avengers movie with him showing
up yeah OS use them to implant his
Essence on the planets Across the
Universe I recovered Earths on my way
here from a place called Missouri the
seedling is protected by a veil of
cosmic energy only a being of celestial
origin can penetrated we have one in
custody you'll be the way to Wi was
heart and I love that she's doing the
Star-Lord entrance and it's starlord
yeah good he's going to see this good
catch cool song though it's always been
one of my mom's favorites it was my mom
loved it too oh yeah you guys can Bond
over your mom's 80s music you don't seem
so bad given where you're from let him
out he's fine little black widow Loki
scene she's going to be manipulating him
because I was was born in the USA why
else do you think I'd 10,000 light
years to get here I'm just trying to get
home security breach or he manipulated
her yeah or it's the switch where are my
particles and where's hope and where's
my key
card she jacked everything oh little
Hulk containment unit oh man he Gass at
you girl that was crazy I noticed a bus
stop about a mile out he doesn't need a
bus bu up no and here I want you to have
this oh there you go this is your mom's
look it's a long ride to Missouri and
she'd be glad to know I'm
sharing thanks a this does seem tender
you guys are making a mistake Peter's
not behind all this it's his
dad he says he's like a weird alien
space Scot or something yeah great blame
the absentee father
we need to study him we need to kill
him he's a threat even without the
seedling he speaks MCR speaks so long as
the boy lives this planet will never be
safe and is that not what we're here to
ensure you're here to do the right thing
Peter deserves our help as much as
anyone she reminds me of
Steve hey Peter why can't hear me why
can't I connect with my son noise
cancelling headphones from 8 eight I
guess I'll have to finish what he
started myself uh thunder guy is it
supposed to be doing this the seedling
is
Awakening another alien vessel about to
make landfall right outside oh
Man Kung Fu well guess that's the dad
girl was right wouldn't I love to have
that printed on a
t-shirt this actually feels like it's
part of the MCU can't fight them both
Let them fight each other Lawson tell me
you've got eyes on that kid up some
Cosmic radiation that's definitely not
of this world but how would Star-Lord
beat him he may be our only hope of
stopping dear old dad you really think a
child is going to be so willing to fight
his own father you're not a parent are
you indey
whoa It's like Man of Steel yeah there's
the Fright
[Music]
burn
cool better yet it's more like Last
Jedi I mean my
preference or has
God not going to go great for you Thor
hand over the seedling and this will all
be over so if you've come to destroy us
you're going to be leaving here very
disappointed I've come to save you it's
always nice they say spreading covering
all that exists until every part of you
is is me
me guys got a bit of an
[Music]
ego faceless henchman it's been a while
if you will not give us back what is
ours we will take it from you never mind
they're all him faced
minions let's take out all those Kurt
[Music]
Russell
cool
Avengers
assembling oh great
[Music]
shot
ohc that was really
cool they have really thrown down way
more of the animation yeah it actually
yeah yeah there's a tangibility oh I got
to go
bigger There's an actual set of scale
which Ant-Man 3 did not have for Antman
not evenia did yeah Winter Soldier do
you
copy just shoot the boy he is busy
trying to kill this kid the Americans
have located the
target I'm Hank hope Dead everything
that's happening it's not me me Tim he
has this power to to get inside my head
see Winter Soldier should be able to
identify with
that but he's not clear
yet come on let's go yeah oh cool oh man
the combination of like the the shifting
around with that the size and even with
a hammer yeah they're really good at the
z-axis up and down and out I thought
maybe if I came back here I wouldn't
feel so alone without my mom it doesn't
even feel like home anymore die it's
like face off Stand Down Soldier I
intercepted your Handler's transmission
it's just you and me pal there is no
me hold that cool edit I like that since
we lost Hope's mom our home hasn't felt
the same either the pain the loneliness
I know it can feel like you're drowning
in it but I haven't and you don't have
to either listen Howard Bucky when you
see that kid all you see is a Target but
I see a future the life he can lead the
good he can do monetary
gains he's been overwhelmed how would
you have hostiles
inbound come join our family Bucky
please well kid what do you say he wants
to adopt
him little brother Stark little brother
Pim I mean
[Music]
oh I didn't know I actually didn't know
if it wasn't animated I I wouldn't know
more but because it's animated I was
like ain't going to shoot they had some
dark what of season one episodes I was
like maybe they kill going to shoot a
kid no the seedling someone doesn't stop
that seedling we are done for I can't
break free no not going to make
it
just taing his head we're not going to
make
it oh as if on Q Wendy crusty jump let's
finally see what this girl can do okay
here we
go
yeah we got it you're alive what you
seem to have fallen in with the wrong
crowd this is my mom's home and I can't
just let you destroy it but that's the
more in you Peter everything dies except
us how could you say that my mother you
said you loved her I like Guardians of
the Galaxy 2 as well yep I enjoy it look
at this father son
struggle you don't have the power to
destroy me but you do a little bit of
you will always live inside of me yes
I've always known you turn out to be a
disappointment this is moving a little
fast for me now yeah it's all a sudden
it's like we got to get to the Third
act man it looks great
though looks great like visually it's
[Music]
awesome
yes Winter Soldier just shoots him in
the head it's
time I found you most
vulnerable what you call it uh light
beer how exotic another chick St as
goose yes the Winter Soldier may be out
there but I'm pretty sure Bucky Barnes
is out there with him he took off the
eyes Shadow but he did not find a change
of clothes still wearing most of the
suit boy may have destroyed ego's
Caporal form but his Planet still lives
perhaps you forgot Goldilocks we have
sort of a team thing going on here yeah
yeah then I suggest you CH up team oh
they got to
avenge hope she didn't be there nope she
has no powers she actually just betrayed
everyone not trustworthy almost caused
the end of the
Earth hope can't be trusted guys should
just because you know not lever it is
take your daughter work
day hereditarily she's important so uh
yeah liked it still more than the first
season but you know what I still love
what do you
love them sponsors
baby thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use for our merch store
and is our gamechanging partner in
e-commerce so whether you're launching a
passion project or scaling to new
heights Shopify is Ecommerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and inore sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic their AI tool that
elevates your business with minimal
effort but seriously reflecting on your
journey using Shopify for www. reation
shop.com it's been transformative the
transition smooth growth exponential
thank you again reject Nation from
simplifying sales to scaling our
offerings Shopify has been a Cornerstone
of our success and Shopify isn't just
for us owers 10% of us e-commerce
backing business businesses big and
small in over 175 countries there are
war-winning support always there to
guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com reex all
overc case shopify.com reex start your
Shopify success story now let's grow
together with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what you
heard is true believe me this channel
knows you can use expressvpn to watch
movies and shows on Netflix that are not
available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over
a 100 countries like a global cinema at
your fingertips it's super easy open
Express VPN switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix
Hulu BBC I player YouTube or more
expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lag for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again anyway K before I interrupted
you with my very important messages from
people who have made life possible to
breathe uh what what did you think of
the episode uh I liked it more than a
lot of the first season wasn't quite as
strong as the uh first episode for me
because we both had the exact same
moment of like well that was rushed like
the uh if the episode had gotten like
five more minutes um it would have been
I I the conversation between ego and his
son was all of a sudden like I've always
hated you and I was like whoa or I've
always expected this of you kind of
turned quickly um it was like the ending
of Guardian it a lot like Guardians 2 it
was a lot it was like 30 minutes at
Guardians 2 condensed into 30 seconds
maybe less yeah I mean I'm assuming you
know everyone that's seen Guardians 2 if
you're watching this you've seen
Guardians 2 but it did make the episode
feel like it was a little disjointed um
overall though man I I this was my most
anticipated episode next to the uh the
the Mad Max episode um from the trailer
uh but this like delivered for me I I
love the80s Avengers um The Avengers is
a is a comic that I've enjoyed since I
started reading comics so it was cool to
see some of the characters in The
iteration that was not quite the comic
but like more familiar um it was great
to see that team Dynamic I thought it
was really cool how they much like the
Jos Weeden Avengers played their power
set off each other and we we talked a
lot about the use of the vectors and the
size and scale and the directing I was
really impressed
overall overall yeah I mean I still
think uh comp
there it it started off stronger to me
and got a little weaker as it went
personally for me um and I was trying to
figure it out because I was trying to
hold on to like the the jovial that the
episode was filling me with because I
was like oh this is really cool we are
doing alternate versions of our Avengers
and having a form in an earlier era um
but it kind of did just kind sort of go
down the path of the things that I
thought were a little lackluster
story-wise of what if season 1 where by
the time we I didn't really feel like we
got to see the uniqueness or
distinctiveness of all the Avengers
characters that that's the appeal of
putting them here yeah after a while
it's like okay yeah when they're first
introduced when they're at Coney Island
and they're fighting you get a tease of
that then I thought it would be like
more Amplified by the time you get to
the finale instead it was a similar
fight but different similar five just
with a bunch of faceless PE like a bunch
of like ego duplicates and they
essentially did plot points similar to
another movie that we've already seen
also the Captain Marvel stand didn't
didn't do anything didn't do jack
right yeah yeah what was her name who
was that I don't know uh Dr Wendy Lawson
Marvell oh she's Marvel right but like
she didn't get that's what I mean like a
Marvel standing she didn't get to do
anything yeah no she didn't do anything
no but she's more like the character oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um yeah I
didn't think she really provided
anything new so I thought like in the be
the first chunk of it was when I thought
we were going to do something really it
felt like it was it was really
interesting setup of okay what if
Star-Lord was abducted instead given to
Ego and he turned and it seemed like he
actually wasn't evil no like six months
he might not have been corrupted as
completely as you know the I it was
still yeah no there's a way to justify
it it's still the setup was infinitely
more interesting than How It ultimately
concluded though oh Daman really what if
they have to fight The Avengers have to
fight Star-Lord and he is he has become
the uh Loki of this world effectively
yeah he has become the loky of this
world has become the god that ego wanted
him to be essentially yeah like that is
a very interesting setup and and he has
caused all this destruction and what do
they do about it like it was fun I liked
hope bonding with him there was a lot of
like really fun things they were doing
and a fun Throwbacks and fun references
like I you know I mentioned with the
Hulk scene and all that stuff that was
fun it was great to see that Tech it was
the lasting impression of the episode
that kind of was like all right yeah I
mean it it did feel more like season one
as far as like and we're going to rush
to the end like that that was my big
issue with season one was it would open
with a premise that for me didn't always
feel as important as the comics but then
it would definitely like once introduced
rushed to the finish line and this had
more of the pacing of what I had
problems with yeah I mean but what do
you guys in the comments think that did
you feel this way about it because for
me yeah I thought like I like getting
Michael Douglas to have have him have be
a lot more fun playing the Ant-Man that
we know from the comics mhm and uh also
with Haley Atwell getting to be old old
Peg old Peg yeah in real time I enjoyed
the relationship between her and John
Slattery because we've never really
gotten to see a lot of that between like
how they knew Steve differently and like
that relationship as how it pertained to
the Winter Soldier that was all
fascinating yeah yeah and it's it's like
aesthetically it was cool to have you
know Goliath there Foster but I wish we
got to get a little again if they if
they actually cut out some of this ego
stuff yeah and they just focused on the
Avengers and dealing with Star-Lord like
you need the ego stuff for the backdrop
I get it for the background explanation
and someone to fight since they don't
want him fighting a kid good luck Young
Avengers but but then it would have
allowed us to actually zero in on like
what makes King tachaka different than
King tala yeah because he definitely
moved uh he had a bit of Swag like tala
but I don't know what his actual
motivations or or personality you know
like hope fan dying little girl got way
more flesh than a lot of the other
Avengers yeah that's why she's a member
of the team exactly for without powers
we don't know why like Dr Wendy Lawson
uh like she got more of a like she could
have used more and and so I really think
that they kind of dropped the ball a
little bit in terms of Storytelling in
the in the last like I don't know how
the episode like 28 minutes yeah last
seven seven or something like that yeah
yeah the third act would definitely felt
like that rush I worry about so it left
so it did kind of leave me a tad
disappointed because it was a little
because everything else leading up to it
I thought was really interesting it kept
getting better and more interesting and
then it kind of just went down a very
predictable cliche path it did wrap
itself up as clean as possible like
let's make sure the kids's good yeah
where especially after a compelling
episode of last episode right like the
only real complaint I had about last
episode was Ronin again was underused it
wasn't really a character and and but
here I'm like oh man they had all this
great stuff and they and they they
didn't really utilize or what instead
they just turned into Guardians too
right and I did enjoy the Avengers setup
more than the the delivery so I I liked
the first two acts and it did Rush and
there's something I do like about Hank
adopting yeah that's
cute yeah yeah and and I think though
that what last episode showed us is you
can do a little bit more of that mature
touch and I think they could have
utilized a little bit more of that
mature handling of it you know like
she's hope and and uh Hank are obviously
haunted by the loss of Janet at this
point in the timeline and they made them
so chipper yeah no real reference except
for the the great prop and they could
have used a tad bit of like emotional
weight and I think that would have
actually made the chipper be more felt
if they balance it out so yeah I know
I'm doing a little bit of the like
revisionist reviewing thingy uh but it
it was all there that's the thing that
put all there they put those puzzle
pieces down they just didn't connect
them yeah yeah yeah but overall still
better than a lot of season one for me
and and the animation still really
spectacular the the sense of scale was
cool and two-thirds of it I still really
enjoyed it's just that last third which
is the it's you know if like the first
if the first third was the weak part to
me I wouldn't really be talking about
that but when it's over you're like well
but when it's the last third that is the
weakest part it's what the episode has
left me with so I guess that's why I'm
like honing in on it so much sure yeah
yeah I I agree uh better than a lot of
season one not as good as episode one of
season 2 good to see those characters
wish the ending had left a little bit
more of a resolution that felt deserved
but overall lot of fun all right guys
what do you think about it leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like and hey we will uh catch
you all soon but before we do this patr
of the day shout
out all right John pick a name Eric
hman Eric horsman you know what I'm
going to get you for Christmas this year
what do we got I am going to get you
uhuh
a you know I just in my head I was like
oh it's Eric it's got to be a good one
and I just got so caught over my own
head of the pressure of
it I can't even think of something right
we we can we can Workshop a couple
things open up you know Amazon or Adam
and eve.com you know whatever we need to
do I I mean you get you out of anyone
you buy our shirts the mostest you've
got a real reject tattoo oh my God you
know you know what I would love to do
but you got to be on your deathbed in
order for me to do this I really I've
really thought about this okay okay is
that when you're on your deathbed yes I
will get an Eric Horseman tattoo
yeah I'm like oh how cool but you got to
be in your death bed yes otherwise you
know who knows you can you're going to
be in the room getting the tattoo cuz
like you might be I could get the T like
you keep that real re said to get your
name it's like
what if he does something that's like
really weird and messed up and and I'm
like ah crap do I really want to be
associated with this guy get a portra I
got to know that you made you made it as
a good
person die sure sure so then get your
tattoo but you I got to get before you
die because then there's if you don't
see it then there's how am I going to
get on camera and get the views for it
you know uh right it's I got to be he's
got to get a reaction to it I gotta like
show it to his place be like we can we
can both do it D subscriber yeah oh wow
John just fallowing my lead well see cuz
you can get his name tattooed oh yeah
just totally hop off my hard work here
just piggyback off of my idea you know
what I don't need your tattoo I'll get
David's I mean I'll get Eric something
totally different yeah why not yeah as
long as it's not better than my tattoo
then we're okay what are you going to
get him okay uh I am going can't think
of anything can you I I think about his
death already you with Eric's face on
them wow so I can watch the quality go
down over time my tattoo is permanent n
dude I'm going to launch a company in
your name call it Eric's cheeks and uh
and I'm going to be strapping people's
cheeks all across this nation with your
face right on the back and it's G to
have a it's going to be you but it's
your head on Michelangelo's David you
know so like oh you would be great
though if it was like half of his face
on each cheek and then you have to
squeeze your cheeks for face to come
together on the form fitting to your
cheeks so that the effect is always oh
gay you would love that that would yeah
imagine I mean like what I he's openly
gay right like I didn't just out him I
would be very surprised if if Eric Horan
was was like what you how dare you
reveal this Eric seems like one of the
most assured and proud people we have
ever interacted with so I I I well I
would be very I'm sorry I feel I would
be very surpris I mean I'm going to put
you back in the closet on your deathbed
just we could always cut this out but
the internet's forever it's true so
someone's gonna come my pres to you is
outing
you and uh and I guess my present is
being an accomplice to
that
anyway not looking forward to when you
die but never you're not going to die we
might get a trending video we
will come to your funeral and live
stream
it and uh with my
Sleepless suit that day yes so the
tattoo is on Full display yeah and I'll
be just strapped in the underoo nothing
else Merry Christmas
[Music]
Eric